-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We've got a full crowd,
a full house.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it was just reported
that the other day a plane
carrying former president Trump
suffered an engine failure
over the Gulf of Mexico
and had to make an emergency
landing in New Orleans.
Yeah, when Trump said,
"Land over there,"
the pilot was like,
"We can't. There's half
a built wall in the way."
[ Laughter ]
Oops.
And following the plane scare,
Trump sent out
a fundraising e-mail
to his supporters
asking for money
so he can buy a new
"Trump Force One" airplane.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Trump wants a new plane
because the only thing
scarier than a crash
is flying commercial.
But in all seriousness, James,
can you play me some music?
Some piano?
[ Dramatic piano music plays ]
Look, guys, Donald Trump's
got to get to places,
and he needs your help.
If you can find it
in your heart to donate --
just $200,000, $300,000 --
it'll go a long way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wants everyone
to buy him a new plane.
Buy him a new plane.
-Yeah, he's got to get
a new plane.
-Meanwhile, President Biden
and several members
of his cabinet
are heading to Philadelphia
to join house Democrats
on their annual retreat.
It was supposed to be
in Vermont,
but they ran out of gas.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's time for Democrats
to get together
for some bonding and fun.
And Nancy Pelosi is so excited,
she hasn't stopped rubbing
her knuckles all day.
[ Applause ]
-Many of you have been there.
-Yeah, yeah. Wow. There you go.
-Have been in and out of Iraq
and Afghanistan over 40 times.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is cool. The musical
guest for the retreat
is D.J. Jazzy Jeff.
Yeah, he's way better than
last year's entertainment --
chuck Schumer rapping.
This is real.
Okay. Very good. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Did you guys hear about this?
This is real,
and this is frightening.
Joro spiders.
Apparently,
there's some spider invasion
coming to the East Coast
in the spring.
Oh, yeah.
And scientists say they're
the size of a child's hand
and they can parachute
from the sky.
[ Laughter ]
I love how scientists are like,
"How should we describe
the size?"
And they're like -- They
settled on "a child's hand."
-Wait, wait, wait.
That's crazy!
I can't believe these things
can parachute.
Look, I'm just gonna
lock myself
in my car
until this all blows over.
-Oh, what kind of car
do you have?
-I actually just bought a BMW.
I'm pretty excited.
-You didn't hear
about the recall?
-Recall?
-Yeah.
It's not good. Roll the clip.
-A major recall of BMW.
More than 900,000 cars and SUVs
have a problem.
The engines can catch fire.
-Catch fire?!
Man, I just bought mine!
-I'm sorry about that, Tariq.
-It's fine.
I shouldn't be driving
on the road anyway.
There's supposed to be
a snowstorm this weekend.
Which is why I have
my trusty snowmobile.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Oh, what?
-Roll the clip.
-An important
snowmobile safety recall.
The machines affected
and the problem
that could leave your sled
in flames.
-[ Applause ]
-Come on!
Why is everything
catching on fire?!
-Yeah, tough break.
I'm so sorry, Tariq.
-It's fine!
I should walk more anyway.
Maybe I'll try
to get some steps in
on my new Fitbit Ionic
smartwatch.
-Customers should
immediately stop using
the Fitbit Ionic smartwatch.
There's been several reports of
the battery burning customers.
-What -- This is going to
ruin my workouts, man!
At least I can still
get some protein
by eating beef-jerky products.
-Over 1,600 pounds
of beef-jerky products
have been recalled.
-What next? You gonna tell me
I can't eat my Great Value brand
tortilla chips?
-A Walmart recall is in effect
for the Great Value brand
tortilla chips.
-I'm done. That's it. That's it.
-Tariq Trotter, everybody.
We can talk about this.
Tariq Trotter.
We can figure it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So sorry. Unfortunate.
-Wow. That's a lot of bad luck.
-Unfortunate, yeah.
Got some business news.
I heard that Kohl's no longer
wants to be a department store
and is turning itself
into a lifestyle brand.
Meanwhile, T.J.Maxx is sticking
with their business plan --
half clothing store,
half fight club.
[ Laughter ]
"Give me that!"
"It's not even my size.
Who cares?!"
[ Laughter ]
And this is fun.
Disney just gave a first look
at Tom Hanks as "Geppetto"
in the live action remake
of "Pinocchio."
Here he is.
Yeah. You know Wilson
the volleyball saw that puppet
and was like,
"Who the hell is he?"
[ Laughter ]
Get this. I read an article
that said before Jeff Bezos
took his big spaceflight
last year,
he was so upset about how his
jumpsuit fit around his crotch
that he flew his tailor in
to fix it.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you know...
There's rich and there's
personal crotch tailor rich.
-Right.
Wow.
-Wow!
[ Applause ]
That's nuts.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking --
Finally, speaking of crotches --
Uh.
I don't think
I've ever said that.
-Wow. Really?
-I've never said that.
Speaking of crotches,
this is a crazy story.
The crotch on a statue of
soccer star Cristiano Ronaldo
is wearing away because tourists
won't stop rubbing it.
-[ Laughter ]
-This is real.
Take a look at this thing.
And there's -- Yeah.
So it's -- There it is.
Not good. Not good.
A few people have spoken out
about the whole thing,
including the statue itself.
Check this out. It said...
Then an old rejected statue
of Ronaldo spoke up and said...
Then the newer statue said...
Then the rejected
Ronaldo statue was like...
Then this plaque of Elvis
Presley spoke up and said...
Then the statue of
Lucille Ball said...
And finally this wax statue...
of Robert Pattinson said...
There you go.
We have a great show.